Darleen snow might just be one of the
most compelling television villains out
there as the deeply proud matriarch of a
heroine distributed family on Netflix is
Ozark she serves as a frequent foil to
criminal newcomer and series protagonist
Marty Byrd Snell's frail frame disguises
a violent character with a hair-trigger
temper quick to kill or maim anyone who
stands in the way of her goals or her
family the child deserves better than I
than a farm stand and a redneck for a
momma and Lisa M rebuilds the role so
well it might be hard to imagine her
playing anyone else but all actors come
from somewhere an emery hasn't let up
since starting her career over 30 years
ago she had an impressive streak of
television and movie appearances before
her seasons long run on Ozark showing up
in everything from 90s primetime dramas
to the Marvel Universe
prior to Ozark Lisa Emory's filmography
was largely a deep well of one-off roles
and guest appearances most notably it
seems like one of her goals has been to
rack up an appearance on each and every
iteration of law and order she stopped
by the flagship dick Wolf's series five
times met with Benson and Stabler on
Special Victims Unit twice and made
one-off appearances on both criminal
intent and trial by jury
more recently Emery appeared in
recurring roles on FX as Lois and the
Marvel superhero series Jessica Jones in
which he played Louise Thompson the
mother of season one's primary villain
kilgrave memories character was a
scientist who experimented on her young
son and an attempt to cure his
degenerative brain disease her trials
were cruel and torturous leading the
kilgrave's warped worldview and
accidentally given him the ability to
control people's minds in the process
when a young kilgrave used this power to
horses mother to burn her face with an
iron she abandoned him and went into
hiding
Henry's appearances on the popular
Netflix show ended when spoiler alerts
kilgrave's succeeded in killing his
mother in brutal fashion during the
seasons ninth episode lisa emery's movie
credits aren't as extensive as her work
in television but she still popped up in
some relatively well known films
eagle-eyed fans can find her turning in
brief but memorable performances and
movies such as Margot at the wedding and
Marcy acts but she has taken a few major
roles here and there check out her work
in the Paul Rudd Tina Fey rom-com
admission for example in that film Emery
plays the mother of phase love interest
and former high school classmate John
Pressman if you're willing to go a
little further back Emery also appeared
in the richer
gear vehicle unfaithful in 2002 despite
all this it's fair to say that our turn
on Ozark is Emrys most exciting work yet
fortunately the color and nuance a
temari's character brings to the show
provides considerable promise for her
future on Ozark given how well-received
Ozarks third season was it seems like a
no-brainer that Netflix will renew the
series for a fourth season and while an
Ozark Season four announcement hasn't
officially happened likely due to the
fact that season three only dropped on
the streamer in March 2020 the general
consensus is that it'll happen sooner
rather than later
beyond the chatter about the timing of
the show's next season and where the
ever twisting story might go from the
events of the season 3 finale there's
been much talk about who will be a part
of the next chapter including memories
Darlene last time Ozark fans saw her
Darlene First Avenger playing more by
shooting Frank cosgrove jr. she
subsequently extended an olive branch by
inviting Frank senior the Kansas City
Mafia leader into a business that's
enough to prove that Darlene's story
isn't over yet there's too many loose
ends from her strange relationship with
roots cousin Wyatt's to her mysterious
dynamic with her mother who some believe
could end up being the central
antagonist of Ozarks sports season by
all accounts it sounds like Gosar fans
haven't seen the last of Darlene Snell
or the exceptionally talented actress
who brings her to life check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]